What if the state covered your cost
of living? Would you still go to work,
go back to school, not work
at all? What would you do?
This concept is called a universal basic
income or ubi and it's nothing less
than the most ambitious social policy
of our times and 2017 basic income is
gaining momentum around the world.
First trials are ongoing or on their way
and the growing number of countries are
considering ubi as an
alternative to welfare.
How would it work and what are the key
arguments for and against right now
people can't radiate, agree what
universal basic income is or should be.
Some want to use it to eliminate
welfare and cup bureaucracy.
Others wanted as a free extra for
existing programs or even want it to be so
high. That work itself becomes
optional. For this video,
we'll talk mostly about
the minimum basic income,
enough money to be above the poverty
line in the u s this means about $1,000 a
month or $12,000 a year.
The money would not be taxed and you
can do whatever you wanted with this and
this scenario,
ubi is aware of transferring the wealth
of a society while still keeping the
free market and tax,
but if we hand out free money,
will people just spend it on
booze and stopped working.
A 2013 study by the World
Bank specifically examined
if poor people waste their
handouts on tobacco and alcohol if
they receive it in the form of cash,
the clear answer, no they
don't. The opposite is true.
Other studies have shown
that the richer you are,
the more drugs and alcohol you can see
in the laziest drunk poor person is a
stereotype rather than reality.
What about laziness?
Universal basic income test runs done in
Canada in the 1970s showed that around
1% of the recipients and stopped working
mostly to take care of their kids.
On average,
people reduce their working hours by
less than 10% the extra time was used to
achieve goals like going back to
school or looking for better jobs,
but if laziness and drugs
are not a huge deal,
why doesn't our current welfare
state solve poverty? Welfare,
or unemployment programs often come
with a lot of strings attached. Mike,
taking part in courses,
applying to a certain number of jobs a
month or accepting any kind of job offer,
no matter if there's a good fit or what's
it pays besides the loss of personal
freedom,
these conditions are often a huge waste
of time and only serve to make the
unemployment.
Statistics seem less bat.
Often your time would be much better
spent looking for the right job,
continuing education,
or starting a business.
Another unwanted side effect of many
welfare programs is that they trap people
in poverty and passive behavior.
Imagine a benefit of $1,000
each month in a lot of programs.
If you earn a single dollar extra,
the whole thing is taken away.
If you take a job that's paying $1,200
you might not only lose your benefits,
but because of your taxes and other costs,
link transportation,
you might end up having
less money than before.
So if you actively trying to better your
situation and your total income is not
improving or even a shrinking welfare
can create a ceiling that traps people in
poverty and rewards.
Passive behavior of basic income can never
be caught and therefore getting a job
and additional income will always
make your financial situation better.
Work is always rewarded
instead of a ceiling.
It creates a floor from which
people can lift themselves up.
But even if you bi is the better model,
is it economically feasible?
What about inflation?
Won't prices just rise making
everything just like it was before?
Since the money is not being
created by magic or printers,
it needs to be transferred from somewhere.
It's more of a shift of funds
than the creation of new ones.
Hence no inflation. Okay,
but how do we pay for it?
There's no right answer here
because the world is too diverse.
How well off a country is.
What the local values are are things
like high taxes or cutting the defense
budget politically acceptable or not?
How much welfare state is already
in place and is it defective?
Each country has its own
individual path to a ubi.
The easiest way to pay for a ubi is to
end all welfare and use the free funds to
finance us. Not only with this make a
number of government agencies disappear,
which in itself saves money. It would
also eliminate a lot of bureaucracy.
On the other hand, cutting them could
leave many people worse off than before.
If the goal is to have a
foundation for everybody,
there still needs to be programs of
some sort because just like countries,
people are not the same.
The second way higher taxes,
especially for the very
wealthy in the u s for example,
there's been a lot of economic growth,
but most of the benefits from it
have gone to the richest few percent.
The wealth gap is rapidly widening and
many argue that it might be time to
distribute. The spoiler was more
evenly to preserve the social piece.
There could be taxes on financial
transactions, capital land value,
carbon or even robots,
but ubi is not necessarily expensive.
According to a recent study,
a ubi of $1,000 per month in the u s
could actually grow the GDP by 12% over
eight years because it would enable
poor people to spend more and increase
overall demand.
What of the people who do the dirty work,
who will work in the fields,
crawl through sewers all if pianos,
if you don't need to, for survival?
Will people still do hard,
boring and unfulfilling?
Labor Ubi might give them enough
leverage to demand better pay and working
conditions.
The study calculated that every extra
dollar going to wage earners would add
about $1 21 to the national economy.
While every extra dollar going to high
income Americans would add only 39 cents.
There would still be very rich and poor
people, but we could eliminate fear,
suffering and existential panic for
a significant part of the population.
Making poor citizens better off
could be a smart economic tactic.
For some,
this isn't enough.
They want a ubi large enough to
live a middle class existence.
If we set the financial obstacle aside,
this idea fundamentally challenges
how our society is constructed.
By owning money, you earn the
possibility to take part in society.
There's determines your
status and options,
but it also forces many
people into spending huge
chunks of their time on things
they don't care about.
In 2016 only 33% of US
employees were engaged at work.
16% were actively miserable
and the remaining 51% we're
only physically present.
Would 67% of people stop working?
If they could?
It would be unfair to
portray workers just a chore.
Work gives us something to do.
It challenges us.
It motivates us to improve
and forces us to engage.
Many find friends or partners at work.
We work for social status,
wealth and optics in the world.
We're looking for something to do with
our lives and for many people work gives
them meaning.
There are other concerns with ubi.
If all welfare programs or
exchanged for one single payment,
this gives the government
a lot of leverage.
Individual programs are easier to attack
or cart than a multitude or populists
might promise drastic changes
to the ubi to get into power.
And a universal basic income doesn't
tackle all problems when it comes to
quality rents.
For example,
while $1,000 might be
great in the countryside,
it's not a lot for expensive
metropolitan areas,
which could lead to poor
people moving outwards.
And the difference between rich and
poor becoming even more extreme.
And of course for some people,
the concept of work itself not being
essential for survival is appalling.
So as the universal
basic income a good idea,
the honest answer is
that we don't know yet.
There needs to be a lot more research,
more and bigger test drugs.
We need to think about what kind of ubi
we want and what we're prepared to give
up to pay for it.
The potential is huge.
It might be the most promising model
to sustainably eliminate poverty.
It might seriously reduced the amount
of desperation in the world and make us
all much less stressed out.
This video was made possible by a
universal basic income provided by you.
Our viewers.
10,000 people around the world.
Gift us a monthly income on
patrion.com/ code's Kazaks.
You enablers to pay salaries
and buy new hardware.
You enabled us to make more videos and
your enablers to spend more time on them.
Quotes cause aren't, would truly not
be what it is today without your help.
You help us stay independent and you
give us the freedom to put quality before
quantity.
Thank you so much.